hello everybody hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome back to
boogeyman is anyone getting nostalgic
because this room I haven't recorded a
video in this room in years or at least
a gameplay video and this is the first
chance that I've gotten to record a
video since I got back to Cincinnati and
the reason for that being I had to deal
with friends and family stuff of course
I had to deal with it it was an ordeal
you know all my nieces and nephews they
wanted to just clamber all over me it
was terrible also besides the holidays I
got sick and my voice is not a hundred
percent just yet but it's getting better
so we're gonna start back with boogie
man we're on night for I'm ready to go
I'm sure it'll be lots of fun and I
won't die in any way and also the other
reason is because oh hey wow you're here
way early
oh I also wanted to point out that
there's tiny box Tim right mm-hm
you wait yes I think I had something for
just outside the window oh yeah well
it's just an hour go back to sleep okay
cause it's just the branches winds don't
don't worry and I'll go back to sleep
you get your bed with me tonight like
being alone
okay whoa whoa whoa hey whoa no I didn't
hear anything
oh crap I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead
Oh what the honking who's with honking
why did it honker Unni okay I actually I
have to put I had one ear off my
headphones just to do the beginning
because I couldn't actually hear myself
but yeah I'm still a little sick my
voice is not a hundred percent and it's
been a while since I just had this one
spooky light right here so it's kind of
fitting that I'm playing a horror game
again and there's like my biggest phobia
having my back to my closets and the
open room because from like since I got
to LA I started recording with my back
up against the wall so nothing could
sneak up on me so this is crazy scary
for me anyway so now I'm gonna lock
myself in I can barely hear myself here
we go
I don't know why I keep getting sick I
always do I swear I did not hear a
goddamn thing with that vent but yeah
there's a tiny box
Tim bro oh that's right
okay there's a tiny box Tim whoa Chism's
I think I heard something outside the
window hell it's just an hour go back to
sleep there were
laws tear branches in the winds - don't
worry yeah go back to sleep straighter
get in bed with me tonight like being
alone another business okay if it helps
you sleep they had an update to the game
since I last played I don't know if they
added anything or made okay that's
annoying thank you oh Jesus
oh god ah they made it so much worse man
night 3 was a breeze I lose my voice hi
whoa whoa Sam hey he's really active I
can't even talk about all the cool
thanks Hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa I can't hear a
goddamn thing half the time huh
oh man he is SuperDuper active oh my god
but this is not okay huh I was hoping
this is gonna be a relaxed Hey
gonna be a relaxing you better go oh
gods froggy
I got scared by froggy hi hi guys
oh god SOI 2 o'clock I've been using too
much battery I'm have to try to hunt one
pretty soon here one when I get him next
I'm gonna go get a battery whoa okay
that was him
go get a battery okay no battery
apparently what the hell I don't even
know what what is that
oh god it's too many things happening ah
okay go battery thank you okay that was
good
hey hey hey
how much appreciate any of this we're
those paintings there before boom I
thought they were a much happier before
I guess everything was much hell hey
Hootie how's it going hooters I'm gonna
lose my voice forgot to obscure Vinod
alright Oh God
it's just weird that he can just dodge
it lightly over the door like that
Oh God I just I'm paranoid because I
think something's behind me and I gotta
check my camera oh god no oh come on who
do come on Hootie hoo oh is Oh jelly
right
Oh mom and dad let's look at your phone
hey I saw that happening know what you
say about Gandalf the dwarf I don't know
tiny about sim please help me I am NOT
okay right now hey hey at least the
night visions working a little better
and maybe it's just a nightlight outside
okay whoa Wow
right outside is helping me quite a bit
spice are you coming yeah I don't like
this it's not good for my voice either
yeah I don't know I keep getting sick
but I think it's just cuz the bacteria
in Cincinnati is a little different than
the bacteria in LA and acclamations
allergies I don't know just trying to
make [ __ ] excuses at this point I
just try to survive oh man oh god
there's something behind me isn't there
oh man oh so much worse Oh what is that
huh oh the light outside broke well
that's good okay hey all right don't
fine we're Jewish with good okay oh god
it's all so weird I will I will admit I
haven't had the chance to record a
horror game in a properly dark room in a
while like because I got finicky about
the lighting of my webcam and making
sure it look good and everything I
forgot that it adds a whole new depth to
the reality of everything all my voice
is going in a million ways uh-huh
oh okay rookie ah I saw you there I saw
you being a creepy crew trying to open
my window all right stop it over to my
air vent
hi hey welcome here get back in the
closet are Kelly okay almost there
almost there
oh there okay
all right all right okay
the boogeyman didn't get us but if I
guys wash my foots by panicking it
really is like way different from when I
was oh my god I mean part of it is that
you become accustomed to being in a
certain space and you feel safe there I
haven't been here in years
I don't feel safe anymore okay so I'm
gonna give my voice a little breather
cuz hot damn I can't panic like that
next time but thank you everybody for
watching and thank you everybody for
being so patient while the videos have
been a little late and delayed I'm gonna
do my best to try to record what I can
but again I don't want to trash my voice
too much I will be back in LA on January
6 and I have been having a great time
spending time with my family that I
haven't seen in a long time and spending
time with friends it's been an awesome
experience but also a too long one like
I I actually do need to get back to work
I feel antsy and cooped up here so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always see you
in the next video bye bye haha oh good
timing though
why go